comment définiriez-vous le terrorisme
la définition les plus courantes c'est
un individu ou un groupe qui fait usage
de la violence à des fins politiques
le gouvernement considère que les
cartels de la drogue
correspondre à cette définition
vous voulez en finir avec tout ça va
falloir me laisser me salir les mains
tu vas avoir le champ libre
l'hébreu commet pas de limites cette
fois à l'eos
tu va nous aider à déclencher une guerre
contre acquis
tout le monde c'est bizarre vous
préférez la compagnie des animaux à
celle des gens oui c'est parce que les
animaux en touche j'ai secours rue
georges quand il avait deux ans
il aurait jamais survécu tout seul il a
une totale confiance en vous hier soir
georges mesurait deux mètres 10 et
pesait 227 kg georges ça va mon vieux tu
la peur tout va bien
ce matin il est passé de m 115 et
approches aniston qu'est ce qui lui
arrive à mon pote
vous connaissez l'édition génétique les
changements seront incroyablement
imprévisible
qu'est ce qui est le seul haut vous ne
saviez pas pour le loup de 9 m
sacrée journée 1
les expériences scientifiques qui nous
tombe du ciel
transporté georges dans cet avion c'est
une erreur monumentale
tout va bien se passer
allons sauver une bretagne
ça va leur revenir nous sommes en dire
à
il faut faire évacuer figallo
georges ilaria demandé ils veulent
l'abattre
ça n'arrivera pas
sow
il n'y a pas quelque chose dans l'eau je
me disais bien que la seule chose qui
nous manquait c'était un crocodile géant
bonjour vous écoutez souhait le matin
faucon part de ce qui se passe à chicago
la vidéo est devenue virale l'homme sans
capuchon a été surnommé le bourreau là
qu'ils volent des voitures at il raison
de se substituer comme ça la justice
c'est devenu un héros et comment était
le tireur
r d'un blanc
j'ai ma famille mais lorsque le soin de
moi des hommes sont entrés chez moi mr
aulas je n'ai pas su la protéger ceux
qui ont fait ça sont là quelque part
mais vous ne pouvez rien faire
est ce que vous me dites bien ne veut
vraiment protéger sieda nuit se racheter
une arme il doit s'en charger lui même
plus de trois jours
alors vous avez pas tués non mais jack
oui j'ai trouvé en pleine plusieurs sait
bien qu'une glace et me donne le temps
de se concentrer à l'école au travail
chargée à bloc
il rassemble
oui
vous avez dernier vous sortez vous voyez
des amis pas tellement
quoi vous fassiez naratil pas d'accord
c'est le promis
mon père m'a toujours dit que la survie
n'est jamais certaine
et quand il n'ya plus de chef à suivre
il faut en devenir un
et qu'en france
ouazine masquer le problème
il y en avait 16 tu as vu ce film épuré
tu sais rien
extraordinaire
mais outre 8 pour mille
ce matin
meyer
ce n'est qu'un corps
ni mauvais ni bon jeu dépendra
je ne voudrais pas vous vexer mais on se
battait en fait
mais on vient de se rencontrer
notre vie
mais
ta monde sans pitié les forts écrasent
les faibles
ja
il
il faut
on ne te dérange pas que je ne sois pas
entièrement humaine
je suis prête à faire n'importe quoi
pour toi je te donnerai tout ce que j'ai
je t'aimerai poker à l'état ils vont
s'en prendre à toi
pourquoi
je pense que tu es tu es quelqu'un de
précieux
et oh
la vie
schivardi qui n'aura pas manqué
nds et d'ouest
vous vous appelez lara nom de famille
croft l'art à ton père nous a quittés tu
pourrais prendre sa relève
vous vous ressemblez tellement
ingénieux
salut ma puce
si tu écoutes ce message c'est sans
doute que je suis mort j'ai découvert
quelque chose
un tombeau appelé la mère de la mort si
le projet de la trinité abouti notre
monde est en danger promets moi de les
arrêter
je te le promets
je crois savoir où mon père est allé
c'est juste au milieu de la mer du
diable ce serait une aventure
la mort n'a rien d'une aventure
vous n'auriez pas dû venir mais je suis
heureux que vous soyez là
qu'est ce que vous savez de mon père je
vois la ressemblance entre la témérité
ferme le tombeau à tout jamais le sort
de l'humanité est entre tes mains
il faut être très prudent de nos jours
le monde est complètement malade je vais
en prendre deux
excusez moi
c'est la première fois que je prends un
train de banlieue et vous tous les jours
depuis dix ans
je veux connaître tout le monde
les habitués haut de gamme
tentant une expérience une expérience
il s'agit de répondre à une simple
question avec quel genre d'homme est
tout
et si je vous demandais de faire une
toute petite chose nouvelle famille je
vous demanderais quel genre de choses
il y à un intrus à bord vous ne savez
pas à quoi il ressemble tout ce que vous
avez à faire
c'est le trouver
pourquoi je le ferai pour la récompense
au merde
ne descendait pas du train avant de
l'avoir trouvée n'en parler à personne
et vous regarde
ne m'obligez pas à faire du mal à
quelqu'un vous aimez
hors de question je refusais
tu sais pas qui tu as vert
ils voiture en vous la panique
tous les passagers de ce train
faut les vivre
mais diable on se fout du train
vous avez jusqu'au prochain arrêt pour
décider quel genre d'homme est tout